[Musik]
sie machen krank und töten nicht nur den
menschen
zigaretten sind auch ein umwelt killer
gerade im filter lauern giftige gefahren
bezogen auf die menge an nikotin ist
eine zigarette sondern viele leute sehen
es überhaupt nicht als problem
betrachten das überhaupt nicht als
männer
der anbau von zigaretten tabak
verbraucht viele ressourcen pestizide
werden eingesetzt
große waldflächen wie hier in afrika
müssen dafür reichen
das ist regionale katastrophe deines
verändert jahre dort auch das regionale
klima also direkt vor ort regenfälle
bleiben aus die insekten kommen nicht
intensiver tabakanbau weggeschnitten
kippen
zigaretten sind ein problem für die
umwelt
[Musik]
sie sammelt alte zigarettenkippen für
eine studie
die gebürtige amerikanerin jamie green
ist für die tu berlin im einsatz
in der hauptstadt vermisst sie plätze an
denen viele zigaretten in der natur
landen so wie dieser bahn eingang
[Musik]
sie will herausfinden wie schnell sich
toxische stoffe aus weggeworfenen
stommeln herauslösen
denn kein müll wird so
selbstverständlich auf die straße
geworfen wie ab gerauchte kippen
[Musik]
pro quadratmeter findet sie
hochgerechnet etwa drei stunden an den
hotspots sind es deutlich mehr
[Musik]
das ist der eigenen zu s-bahn und da
findet man typischerweise viele gucken
wollen die leute müssen sich ein um ihre
bahnen zu bringen und die haben keine
zeit um ihre zigaretten aufzubrauchen
dann ist so relativ viel tabak noch
jemand aber in eine kippa desto mehr
nikotin ganz klar kippen sind kleinste
darin enthalten ist nikotin
selbst wenn die stadt hier reinigen
lässt auch solch hoch frequentierten
plätzen sind die zigarettenstummel
einfach nicht wegzubekommen
so lagert sich das gift in den kippen
tage lang an und täglich kommt neues
dazu angeschlossen sind das heißt man
kann nicht mit einem besen hier ein
man kann eigentlich nur mit den fingern
die aufheben und das macht keine die
mühe die bleiben liegen und werden dann
bei den nächsten regen events alle außer
nikotin ist in wasser gelöst und geht
dann in der oberflächen abschluss das
heißt es geht in die kulisse ein
schon in wenigen minuten hat sie einen
ganzen beutel für ihre studien zusammen
gesammelt
man kann davon ausgehen dass jedes mal
dass es regnet dass ein von diesem platz
konzentration von nikotin eingesetzt
etwa 5,6 millionen zigaretten werden
jährlich gehort 4,5 millionen davon
landen als kippe in der natur auf der
straße oder in gullys die müssen von der
stadt gesäubert werden jeden tag fahren
reinigungsmaschinen aus um die über
130.000 straßenabläufe der stadt hamburg
turnusmäßig auch von den klippen zu
befreien der aufgezogene müll geht dann
später in die verbrennungsanlage landen
die kippen und die darin enthaltenen
gifte allerdings im system der
kanalisation werden sie dort zum problem
kippe es schlecht kippe ist einmal
einfach erst mal müll und gehört in den
mülleimer
das nikotin ist gift und das vergiftet
im grünen das gewässer direkt an der
regenrinne sation oder eben das abwasser
was sowieso gereinigt werden muss wird
weiter vergiftet und das gift ist
einfach das problem die mikroorganismen
im klärwerk sind alle ich nicht dafür da
gift nikotin zu eliminieren das können
sie eigentlich gar nicht und deswegen
ist es eigentlich fast nicht möglich das
abwasser vom nikotin zu befreien
das klärwerk in hamburg selbst hier
können die dafür vorgesehenen mikroben
das giftige nikotin nicht zu 100 prozent
abbauen
dazu kommt das problem mit den kleinen
zigarettenfilter die rutschen zum
großteil durch die sogenannte
rechenanlage sie müssen aufwendig mit
kleineren 7 herausgefiltert werden um
schließlich in die verbrennungsanlage zu
gelangen
sonst würden sie in die elbe fließen und
dort die umwelt belasten
londondie kippen allerdings als achtlos
weggeworfener müll direkt in flüssen und
seen vergiften sie ungefiltert das
wasser über 4000 chemikalien sind in
kippen enthalten manche direkt im tabak
andere im filter oder sie entstehen beim
verbrennungsprozess darunter ansehen
gefährliche schwermetalle wie blei und
kupfer direkt auf lebewesen und pflanzen
wirkt vor allem das nikotin pestizide
weil es einfach sehr gut
mit hilfe einer sogenannten up
rauchmaschine will die forscherin
herausfinden wie viel nikotin durch die
kippen in die umwelt gelangt dabei
interessiert eine frage ganz besonders
was passiert mit dem gift in den stummel
wenn diese mit wasser in berührung
kommen etwa wenn es regnet
um das herauszufinden produzierte nigrin
normierte kippen die 3,7 cm lang sind
das entspricht der durchschnitts länge
eines weggeworfenen stummel diese extra
angefertigten kippen braucht sie weil
ihre auf der straße gesammelten bereits
ausgewaschen sind
dann setzt sie die so erzeugten stummel
künstlichen regengüssen aus das wasser
läuft über die kippen und wäscht das
darin enthaltene nikotin aus das
aufgefangene wasser wird dann analysiert
das ergebnis pro kippe gelangen
durchschnittlich 2 milligramm nikotin in
die umwelt bei manchen waren es bis zu
sechs milligramm
dabei sind laut eu tabak abfälle mit 0,5
milligramm nikotin schon als gefährlich
einzustufen was wir gefunden haben dass
es ist das nikotin löst sich sehr
schnell
nikotin ist sehr wasserlöslich und es
lässt sich sehr schnell die ersten zwei
regen events kommt 60 prozent von
nikotin raus nur 30 minuten dauert es
bis ein großteil des nikotins aus der
kippe herausgewaschen ist und seine
giftige wirkung im wasser entfaltet
welche folgen das hat wird hier in san
diego untersucht an der kalifornischen
küste gibt es weit strengere verbote als
in deutschland
auch am strand wer hier raucht bekommt
ein bußgeld verpasst professor thomas
nowotny ist ehemaliger mitarbeiter des
gesundheitsministeriums und forscht nun
an der universität san diego er hat den
kippen den kampf angesagt denn die
ergebnisse seiner studien sind
alarmierend er fand heraus nikotin im
wasser hat auswirkungen auf die
lebewesen darin studienobjekt sind diese
jungen regenbogenforellen noch schwimmen
sie im klaren wasser später wird
professor nowotny sie einer nikotin
brühe aussetzen
die dosis 10 kippen auf vier liter
wasser die zigarettenfilter sind wie
eine art teebeutel sie sondern
chemikalien ab von denen wir wissen dass
sie giftig sind
wir können beweisen dass fische und
andere lebewesen im wasser durch den
zigarettenfilter beeinträchtigt werden
über nacht wurde das wasser mit dem
nikotin vermischt jetzt gibt der
forscher diese brühe in ein aquarium
[Musik]
dort hinein kommen die jungen
regenbogenforellen die bislang im klaren
wasser geschwommen sind
[Musik]
schon nach ein paar sekunden reagieren
die fische erst nur ein paar wenige dann
immer mehr
das nikotin zeigt seine wirkung
sie scheinen wie gelähmt
einige spucken aus
drehen sich durch links
[Musik]
die tiere erleiden einen nerven schock
aufgrund der vergiftung
[Musik]
wir haben herausgefunden dass bereits
ein aufgelöster zigarettenfilter in
einem liter wasser die hälfte der fische
tötet die wir der gift lösung für vier
tage ausgesetzt haben
die todesrate in dem experiment ist 50
prozent wir sehen hier und jetzt die
heftigen auswirkungen an den fischen die
gerade in einer lösung mit zehn
zigarettenfilter 9 4 litern schwimmen
die fische zeigen anzeichen einer
neurologischen vergiftung das ist nicht
überraschend
abgesehen von schwermetallen etr phenol
und anderen chemikalien ist
hauptsächlich nikotin in der lösung die
wir aus den filtern produziert haben und
wir sehen die fische leiden deutlich
unter dieser eindrücken
nach ein paar minuten erholen sich die
fische von dem schock doch der schein
trügt würden sie länger im wasser
bleiben wäre das ihr sichere tod
professor nowotny und sein team
untersuchen die körper der
kontaminierten vor allen die frühere
tests nicht überlebt haben
dabei finden sie in den fischen an
gelagerte toxische substanzen die aus
den zigarettenkippen stammen
nowotnys mitarbeiterin befürchtet
auswirkungen auch auf den menschen
wir stießen auf nervengifte die
natürlicherweise im tabak und in qualm
enthalten sind
diese gifte sind auch in der wasser
lösung aus den zigaretten filtern zu
finden
aber was viel wichtiger ist einige
dieser alkaloide finden wir in hoher
konzentration in dem fisch selbst das
bedeutet wenn wir den fisch essen sind
auch wir menschen diesen chemikalien
ausgesetzt
das nervengift nikotin kommt also durch
die nahrungskette zu uns menschen zurück
für professor nowotny spielt dabei der
filter der zigarette eine entscheidende
rolle
ich glaube worüber wir dringend
nachdenken müssen ist nicht nur das
aufsammeln von einzelnen
zigarettenkippen
wir könnten eine million davon auch
sammeln wir würden nicht mal in die nähe
einer lösung des problems kommen
das produkt muss aus umweltschutzgründen
reguliert werden und meine erste
forderung wäre den zigarettenfilter zu
verbieten ohne filter bedeutet
allerdings dass raucher mehr schadstoffe
aufnehmen als ohnehin schon
ein radikaler vorschlag
[Musik]
doch tiere und umwelt würden geschont
unsere studie ist ein alarmsignal
wir müssen das kippen problem dringend
weiter wissenschaftlich untersuchen
wir glauben wenn wir die
zigarettenfilter in der umwelt entsorgen
verschwinden sie einfach als sind
ungefährlich
wir werfen sie weg aber sie kommen zu
uns zurück an diesem strand in
warnemünde ist rauchen nicht verboten
nur offiziell unerwünscht
geraucht wird trotzdem hier am strand
ist die kippe die am häufigsten
anfallende müll
das fanden küsten schützer nach mehreren
sammelaktionen heraus
[Musik]
sie haben darauf reagiert und bereits
einige aschenbecher aufgestellt
ok -magazin werden 20.15
doch das reicht ihnen nicht sie wollen
das verhalten der raucher ändern denn
sie finden selbst um einen einzigen
aschenbecher herum im kleinen radius in
wenigen minuten immer noch über 50
betten
ja
nicht nur das gift dieser kippen ist ein
problem sondern auch das material aus
dem der filter hergestellt ist
[Musik]
also wir sehen eben hier welche wonach
der zigaretten fehlt damit papier
umhüllt ist und die die halt schon älter
sind wo das papier eben schon weg ist
das hat sich also schon abgelöst und ist
wahrscheinlich auch schon verrottet aber
der väter ist eben das problem dieses
cellulose acetat kann sich nicht
biologisch abbauen
wir wissen von studien raus im süßwasser
dass so ein väter ungefähr zehn bis 15
jahre braucht um abgebaut zu sein
im salzwasser das heißt wenn wir das
jetzt ins meer bringen würden dann kann
das bis zu 400 jahre dauern bis ich
sowas zersetzt solange richten filter
schaden im meer an die lobbyorganisation
der hersteller der deutsche
zigarettenverband glaubt das nicht
er schützt die abbaubarkeit der filter
etwas anders sein
der normale zigarettenfilter aus
cellulose acetat ist biologisch abbaubar
er braucht eine gewisse zeit ist
unterschiedlich wie er sich im boden
zersetzt es kommt bisschen hängt von der
lichteinstrahlung ab es ist hängt davon
ab wie er sich im wasser zersetzt das
ist ein längerer prozess
und wir arbeiten gemeinsam mit den
herstellern aus der chemischen industrie
daran dass diese zeiten sich verkürzen
die firma gizeh hat das jetzt schon
geändert mit einem filter aus papier der
in wenigen wochen abreißt eigentlich
produziert das deutsche unternehmen
filter für selbst gedrehte zigaretten
diese sind etwas dünner als die
herkömmlichen ansonsten identisch
die normalen filter aus acetat machen
den rauch weicher erklärt
geschäftsführer christian hinz doch der
nachteil ist das gewebe es dicht wird
verklebt und es dadurch schwerer
abbaubar als papier filter
hier sehen wir die klassische methode
wie jeder azetat filter hergestellt
werde nicht nur bei uns sondern gesamten
industrie das sieht so aus wenn man dann
sieht wie gummi merkt man schon dass
faltet sich dann so aus wie watte
ich habe mal zur demonstration was wir
vorhin eine papier filtermaschinen
gesehen haben mitgebracht so dass kriege
ich natürlich auch durchgezogen ist
papier und da zeigen sich ja schon die
unterschiede was das thema abbaubarkeit
angehe
diese anlagen stellen filter aus
ungleich dem papier her
die maschinell zusammengefaltet werden
im moment die einzigen in deutschland
doch bei manchen konsumenten ist das
ungleiche papier nicht besonders beliebt
der rauch wird dadurch härter
auch zigarettenhersteller haben solche
filter schon mal benutzt aber dann
wieder verworfen
diese will dabei bleiben trotz des
mehraufwands
der gesamte prozess ist teurer
er läuft schon langsamer das heißt die
ausbringungsmenge ist deutlich geringer
aber von der theorie her könnte es
natürlich jeder in der industrie machen
wenn das nicht nur genug anstrengen
würde die filter bauen sich zwar in der
natur schneller ab das problem mit dem
gift in der zigarette bleibt allerdings
vor allem wenn kippen nach wie vor
achtlos weggeworfen werden und niemand
sich für sie verantwortlich führt
bürgerinitiativen und
naturschutzorganisationen veranstalten
immer wieder sammelaktionen wie hier in
greifswald
sie prangern das fehlende bewusstsein
für das ausmaß des problems an
jedes jahr fällt eine unvorstellbare
menge an zigaretten müller gleich mal
raus holen wenn wir dieser legen
doch die aufklärung fängt gar nicht
immer beim raucher sonja von eichborn
trifft den bürgermeister von greifswald
selbst bei amtsträgern ist die
umweltbelastung durch zigarettenstummel
oft noch gar nicht angekommen
also die erste wichtige erkenntnis war
für mich tatsächlich dass diese kippen
so giftig sind und so belastend sind
ich muss gestehen dass war mir nicht
bekannt aber ich habe auch nicht darüber
nachgedacht das heißt man muss aus
verschiedenen gründen tatsächlich was
tun um diese kippen dorthin zu besorgen
befördern wo sie hingehören eine
weggeworfene zigarette scheint vielen
harmlos doch die menge macht's 750.000
tonnen wiegt der kippenberg der so
jährlich weltweit entsteht
doch die belastung durch die stummel ist
nicht das einzige umweltproblemen von
zigaretten
sonja von eichbaum sammelt weltweit
infos über tabak anbaugebiete
in schwellen und entwicklungsländern
gerade in afrika werden schon seit
vielen jahren ganze wälder für den
tabakanbau gerodet holz wird zur
trocknung der tabakblätter verwendet in
tansania und malawi werden jedes jahr
jeweils flächen von 50 bis 60.000 hektar
wald vernichtet weltweit kommen etwa
200.000 hektar gerodet ewald zusammen
pro jahr das entspricht sechs mal der
fläche von münchen
dazu kommt nach den rodungen entzieht
tabak dem boden viele nährstoffe
wenn der boden erstmal in den tabak welt
verwandelt ist ist ja nach zwei bis drei
jahren auch so kaputt und ausgelaugt
dass da nichts mehr wächst deswegen wird
ja was neues gerodet und da wird schon
sehr lange nichts mehr wenn der boden
trocken und bröselig ist gerade in so
regionen im südlichen afrika
dann wird dann erodiert der und dann
wird im prinzip eine welt in der wüste
daraus tabak ist empfindlich und dadurch
pflegeintensiv
dünger und chemische hilfsmittel sind
für viele bauern unerlässlich bedeutet
sehr intensiven einsatz von pestiziden
weil es eine monokultur ist und weil es
wegen jeder monokultur halt bestimmte
schädlinge gibt die sie gerne besuchen
und die ganze ernte ausfallen lassen
können und deswegen werden sie ja viele
pestizide eingesetzt sehr viele
unterschiedliche zum teil welche die
hier sogar verboten sind und wie es mit
pestiziden immer ist sie gehen in den
boden
mit dem regen werden sie ausgewaschen in
den boden und bleiben in den böden oder
werden von da weiter ausgewaschen auch
ins grundwasser ein lohnendes geschäft
5,6 billionen gerauchten zigaretten
weltweit pro jahr
der umsatz liegt allein in deutschland
bei über 20 milliarden euro jährlich
die waldrodungen seien beim tabak eher
gering meint der deutsche
zigarettenverband vergiftungen durch
nikotin seien eine frage der
konzentration
zudem gäbe es gegen studien für das
kippen problem bietet der verband solche
taschen aschenbecher natürlich hat das
umweltbewusstsein zugenommen und
verbraucher achten sehr viel stärker
darauf wie produkte hergestellt werden
und das ist ihr gutes recht und ersetzt
die industrie natürlich auch zu recht
unter druck dass sie diese erzeugnisse
achtsamer herstellt und das ganze
lieferketten auch stärker überprüft
werden
und wir haben ein eigenes interesse
daran um unsere geschäftsmodell
langfristig nachhaltig zu gestalten dass
diese produkte
diese akzeptanz finden und deshalb auch
verbraucher informiert sind genuss
braucht verantwortung für die umwelt
allerdings erst wenn der verbraucher
danach fragt
dabei gibt es nachhaltigen bio
tabakanbau hier in der pfalz ist markus
fischer bauer in dritter generation
er pflanzt neben normalem tabak auch die
bio variante an
ohne dünger pestizide oder insektizide
für den tabak bauern viel aufwendiger
für die umwelt besser
der mehraufwand kostet
ein kilo bio tabak ist etwa zwei euro
teurer als der konventionelle
[Musik]
in biologischer anbau ist nicht so dass
ich einfach gymnastik nehmen kann kann
die lösung ein keeper sondern wirklich
biologische was ich malen wir sagen dazu
in der polsterei getrocknete kuhscheiße
quasi aufgelöst in wasser hat sogar
kaulquappen fühlen sich hier wohl
bei konventioneller anbaumethode würde
es ihnen nicht so gut gehen
wir sind dann behandelt damit so mittel
gegen würmer auf dem feld alles so also
dass wir dachten wahrscheinlich die
kaulquappe abtötet das kommen immer
wieder dadurch aber so wie hier bei der
biologische pflanze des fliedner halle
beim konventionellen auf dem bio tabak
feld wachsen unkraut und gräser die
dürfen nicht mit gift bekämpft werden
den höheren preis für den anfälligeren
bio tabak zahlen viele umweltbewusste
raucher gern doch der bio tabak hat in
deutschland eine schwere zukunft denn
die werbung damit ist in europa nicht
mehr erlaubt die verbraucherzentrale
hatte geklagt beschreibungen wie
natürlich und natur reihen sind verboten
denn auch bio zigaretten seien ein
gesundheitsgefährdendes produkt
verbraucher diese begriffe sehr schnell
positiv besetzen und denken könnten
diese zigaretten sind vielleicht weniger
gesundheitsschädlich und das ist leider
nicht der fall
die industrie lässt ihre bio tabak
bauern jetzt wohl fallen weil der
werbeeffekt fehlt markus fischer will
auf seinem öko fällt jetzt notgedrungen
auf mais oder weizen umsatteln
kein hersteller kaufte bio tabak um
damit normale zigaretten zu produzieren
zu teuer die schuld sieht er vor allem
bei den verbraucherschützern gerät hat
alles gemacht ja sogar t-shirts
regenjacke alles und ja mehr wurden
schon von denner ausgestattet und
bekamen die sache und dann bekam ich vor
zwei jahren dann da ruft wie das ganze
jetzt so langsam ins liedern gerade ist
wir müssen alle typisch verdichteter
darf nicht mehr natural american spirit
drauf stehen sondern nur noch american
spirit ich finde es einfach nur traurig
dass das dass sowas bestimmt wird dass
es einfach niemals seine sicher zeigt
das produkt wie salat blumenkohl
brokkoli genau so und so ist das
ökologisch erzeugter tabak warum darf
der keinen natural drauf stehe also ja
das macht einen tabakpflanzen ich
stutzig
zwar ist bio tabak nachhaltiger für die
umwelt im anbau aber auch hier sammelt
sich gift im filter
seit jahrzehnten haben sich raucher das
wegschleppen angewöhnt ein umdenken wird
sehr schwierig fürchten nicht nur die
umweltschützer aus warnemünde raucher
wollen ihre kippen schnell und bequem
loswerden und nicht lange mit sich herum
tragen haben ihre umfragen ergeben
es kam eben raus dass sie selber sich
einschätzen sie würden mindestens 20
meter laufen und wir können aber in den
daten sehen dass es eigentlich nur zehn
meter sind die sie gehen alle zehn meter
ein aschenbecher
das ist eher unrealistisch
und selbst wenn meint thomas nowotny in
san diego mit erziehungsmaßnahmen ist
vielen rauchern nicht beizukommen
schauen sie mal hier das ist eigentlich
eine effektive lösung schön sichtbar ein
kippen sammler und vor dem tabakgeschäft
steht noch einer
aber wie sie sehen können
obwohl es hier zwei optionen gibt auf
der straße liegt die kippe
professor nowotny sieht die
verantwortung bei den
zigarettenherstellern sie müssten sich
wesentlich mehr um die umweltfaktoren
von tabakanbau und gift in den filtern
kümmern
aus seiner sicht tun sie zu wenig
deswegen hofft er auf schärfere gesetze
wir müssen versuchen das produkt
zigarettenfilter so zu verändern dass
der umgang damit nicht mehr so wichtig
ist das beste wäre die filter zu
verbieten
das ist die einfachste und
kostengünstigste lösung für die
tabakindustrie
das wäre wichtig für die umwelt
einerseits würde es den kippen müll
nicht mehr geben aber auch raucher
würden zweimal überlegen ob und wie sie
weiterhin rauchen wollen wenn es ohne
filter nicht mehr so bequem ist
seine vision ist ganz einfach ohne
filter gäbe es weniger raucher und damit
weniger probleme für die umwelt
[Musik]